[SPEAKER_04]: Say enough well, son, as the Marine units are ambushed.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so... Guys become... First off, this is the upper level.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is the upper level.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is kind of like the tower platform, which is about halfway down.
[SPEAKER_04]: Three-quarters of the way down.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you are not going to be able to get there from here.
[SPEAKER_04]: You have to go in the door, up a level, and you'll be there.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you're looking at this tower from the top down.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is the entranceway.
[SPEAKER_04]: There are stairs that go up.
[SPEAKER_04]: Stone at the bottom.
[SPEAKER_04]: But after you get past that foundational stone, there's a doorway which is shut at this point.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_03]: Kind of like stairs up.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is lower and that's that high.
[SPEAKER_03]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's enough.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll initiative.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let me do this.
[SPEAKER_04]: What's that?
[SPEAKER_03]: You have a question, Gap?
[SPEAKER_03]: I have a question on gameplay from reading the player's handbook.
[SPEAKER_03]: Correct me if I'm wrong, but I was reading that initiative is rolled by each in each round.
[SPEAKER_03]: And each person individually has the initiative role because it could be Tyrus and then two archers and then all of a sudden it's Folsom.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, the way I do it with groups like this.
[SPEAKER_03]: This would be bigger and take forever to do that, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: I do, each player character gets their role because they have dexterity and so on.
[SPEAKER_04]: The uniformed Marines all have stats that are similar, so they're gonna roll as one thing.
[SPEAKER_04]: Same thing with your opponents here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So we'll start that with, what I'll do is I'll say the Guardsmen, or Marines, are the M. And then this is Aristotle.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is Folsom.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is Merrick.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then here are your opponents.
[SPEAKER_04]: Each round, we'll wipe those off after we've gone through it, and I'm going to keep the tick mark right here of how many rounds we go through.
[SPEAKER_04]: I might move this down to here.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just want to run out of the table the first time.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's later on.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll start marking it with Sharpies later on.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's great.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so I'm going to roll for your opponents.
[SPEAKER_04]: They get a 1920, because they have a plus one for this round.
[SPEAKER_04]: Motherfucker.
[SPEAKER_03]: Which makes sense, because they got their drop-on.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, now, your Marines, one of you guys were.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're commanding them, or you're more with them.
[SPEAKER_03]: So this is for the Marines, not my own?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Five, six, seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: They get a seven.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is for me.
[SPEAKER_04]: Three, plus your dexterity of five.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, so I get...
[SPEAKER_04]: You get a three, you get a five.
[SPEAKER_04]: You act after your Marines.
[SPEAKER_04]: Where's that?
[SPEAKER_04]: The plus is right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, for the initiative, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: That says two!
[SPEAKER_01]: Three?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep, so five as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Five as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or simultaneous.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll go.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fifteen plus three.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fifteen plus three is eighteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you can't beat them, but you'll act before anybody else.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fourteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, we'll do the deal.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now, the front marines have an AC of 17.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's a little pull before we start.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here's the way I normally do it when we are doing what the Marines are doing.
[SPEAKER_04]: The Marines actually have taken their action to be dodgy.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's what doing a shield wall is all about.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right, so...
[SPEAKER_04]: They're going to be shot at at disadvantage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: But... Let me see about that.
[SPEAKER_04]: I roll all the guys and if somebody gets hit...
[SPEAKER_04]: Then I roll again at disadvantage to see if that's lower or not.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right, so this is the way to do it.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm not going to roll these as being two at once.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm going to roll five of the guy's dice, these attacks on these guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then if somebody gets hit, I roll again because it's a disadvantage and if it's lower, that means he's not hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: So the Marine, the Marines have an AC of 17, scale nail plus shield.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I'm going to go down the row, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, from here, fire it on these dudes, and assign what the attacks are.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I'll usually start this as this guy goes to the first eye and then I'll just orbit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, so this is the first, let's see, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14.
[SPEAKER_00]: 14 guys firing from there.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I'll do the first six.
[SPEAKER_04]: We just start like that.
[SPEAKER_04]: That would be a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: That would be a miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: Miss, miss, miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy, this is six guys, this guy, twelve plus three, miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, the first six guys, one, two, three, four, five, six, all misses.
[SPEAKER_04]: Next, six.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's going to be on that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's a possible hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: All of these are misses, and I reroll these to see if they get hit or not.
[SPEAKER_04]: One guy gets hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: The last guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, no.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy gets hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's the guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: And he takes one die ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: Where's my one die ten?
[SPEAKER_04]: Pumpkin.
[SPEAKER_04]: He takes nine, ten points of damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he is one, two, three, four, five, six, seven down.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's a whole character sheet for that guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Backstory's got two kids.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not quite, but you know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is this your pencil?
[SPEAKER_03]: I think that is my pencil.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, so that guy takes ten points of damage.
[SPEAKER_03]: That guy's the one that's missing a thumb.
[SPEAKER_03]: I remember it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I like that damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, 10.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not going to be able to remember that, but he is basically B2.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm going to mark him as B2 now.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then, so that is 6 for 6.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's 12.
[SPEAKER_04]: Two more guys firing on these guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: 11 and 10 misses.
[SPEAKER_02]: Also, you just get to add more guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: More guys, but no more.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nine firing in this way.
[SPEAKER_00]: But it's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20.
[SPEAKER_04]: So they're at long range, which means they fire at disadvantage, but you don't have double disadvantage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to put a little dash there for 20 or whatever?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's 100 feet away from those dates, is what that means.
[SPEAKER_04]: So nine more crossbow bolts on you guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: It could be the same for us going in the direction.
[SPEAKER_04]: Correct.
[SPEAKER_04]: So here are the rolls.
[SPEAKER_04]: First six.
[SPEAKER_04]: There is fifteen, eighteen, and eighteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Those are possible hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I will roll them randomly to see which guys get hit on that first front row.
[SPEAKER_04]: But here's four more because there are nine guys shooting.
[SPEAKER_04]: Three more.
[SPEAKER_04]: Misses.
[SPEAKER_04]: Randomly, the two people that are going to be hit are eight and three, so three, this guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: That guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thumbless there.
[SPEAKER_00]: This guy takes
[SPEAKER_04]: Eight, nine points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Just like thumbless.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's indexless.
[SPEAKER_01]: But he took ten.
[SPEAKER_01]: Really?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, he took ten.
[SPEAKER_00]: And this guy takes six, seven points of damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, the first round.
[SPEAKER_04]: Crossbow bolts fly down upon you from across the way and then up on the thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: You see these.
[SPEAKER_00]: These are not human beings.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're like red-faced creatures.
[SPEAKER_04]: Red-faced men.
[SPEAKER_04]: Humanoids.
[SPEAKER_04]: But you've never seen their life before.
[SPEAKER_04]: Have I seen their life before?
[SPEAKER_04]: What's your insight?
[SPEAKER_04]: Plus six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twenty-side?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_03]: Twenty-side dies.
[SPEAKER_03]: Four.
[SPEAKER_03]: No.
[SPEAKER_03]: Have I, in just my adventures, Witcher insight?
[SPEAKER_03]: Plus four.
[SPEAKER_03]: Roll.
[SPEAKER_03]: Twenty-four.
[SPEAKER_03]: Come with me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, you heard Kormurg talk of these creatures.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_00]: When he traveled into the Duchy of Birkhoff, he said that they were used as guards sometimes by nobles.
[SPEAKER_00]: Strange.
[SPEAKER_00]: These are affiliated with the plar of Birkhoff.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to move?
[SPEAKER_02]: I am firing.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to fire.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you can move 30 feet.
[SPEAKER_02]: Always.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then you can use your action to attack or you can use your action to hide or whatever.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't think you have a skill that gives you a bonus action.
[SPEAKER_02]: I wouldn't know.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you had a spell, which you don't have any spells, it would possibly take a bonus action, but you can always move 30 feet.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's 30 feet.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll go 30 to the right over here.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you want to go 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
[SPEAKER_04]: Run that way as you fire.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you book that way.
[SPEAKER_03]: There's five.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then one more, six.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's thirty feet.
[SPEAKER_04]: Five times six.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you want to fire at the closest or who do you want to fire at?
[SPEAKER_02]: The two closest.
[SPEAKER_02]: Am I allowed to do that?
[SPEAKER_04]: You are allowed to, you get one attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, but I said I have two.
[SPEAKER_04]: I can shoot twice on the longbow, is that correct?
[SPEAKER_04]: When you reach fifth level, you get something called extra attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you don't automatically get two shots for the longbow, you only have one.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, I'll just shoot the closest guy then.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, what's your plus with your arrows?
[SPEAKER_04]: Longbow attack bonus is plus five.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Plus five.
[SPEAKER_04]: You fire at this guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: He has...
[SPEAKER_04]: An AC of 16, but without a shield it's only 14, so you need to roll a 9 to be able to hit it.
[SPEAKER_04]: With a d20?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_04]: You hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Just barely.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh wait, no.
[SPEAKER_04]: Is that a 9 or a 6?
[SPEAKER_04]: You miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: Is it a 9 or a 6?
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you know?
[SPEAKER_03]: There'll be a dot on it.
[SPEAKER_02]: It was a dot on the top of it.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, that's a 9.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's a 9.
[SPEAKER_04]: You miss because he has partial cover, which gives him a plus two to his AC.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you roll a 14, you need to get a 16 to be able to hit him.
[SPEAKER_04]: These guys all have what's called half cover, which gives them plus two AC.
[SPEAKER_04]: These guys have three quarters cover, which gives them plus... What is that?
[SPEAKER_04]: I think that's plus two AC as well.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you go.
[SPEAKER_04]: You've gone.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, that's me now.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gouge.
[SPEAKER_03]: The wall looks scalable.
[SPEAKER_04]: I've been here before.
[SPEAKER_04]: You could scale it, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: But I mean, if you're on the wall and they know you're going up, they can fire down at you at advantage.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you're going to be able to scale half your speed every time.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's 30 feet up, so you'd have to do that for two rounds.
[SPEAKER_04]: But yeah, you could possibly do it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You'd probably want to be hidden before you started doing it so you couldn't see where you were.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well...
[SPEAKER_03]: I shove an elbow.
[SPEAKER_03]: Follow.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I'm doing 30 feet this way, shooting at that guy.
[SPEAKER_03]: The goal is to get cover out of there.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_04]: You want to run to there?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now, you can use your action to dash, which means you run twice, but you want to attack, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: If you dash, you move your distance.
[SPEAKER_04]: You get to go 60 feet.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to stop and fire at the corner.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: Roll your attack.
[SPEAKER_03]: What do you get you?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, you're right there.
[SPEAKER_03]: So on... Dexterity is plus six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Your attack bonus should be there for your heavy crossbow.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's in the middle right there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Plus 7.
[SPEAKER_04]: Minus 2.
[SPEAKER_04]: His AC is 16, so you need to roll a 9 to hit him.
[SPEAKER_03]: But he's in half cover?
[SPEAKER_04]: He is in half cover, which gives him a plus 2 AC.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's got scale mail on, which gives him an AC of 14.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, 16.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right?
[SPEAKER_04]: And then he has 16 normally with his shield.
[SPEAKER_04]: However, he doesn't have a shield, so he goes to 14.
[SPEAKER_04]: But he has half cover, which means he goes back to 16.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: Just barely misses him.
[SPEAKER_04]: The crossbow bolt goes above his head and sticks into the thing there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's move, then attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: That is Aristotle.
[SPEAKER_04]: Number, let's see, seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's the Marines.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: These guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wing to here.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two.
One, two.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Five.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is you.
[SPEAKER_00]: These guys will go one, two, three, four, five to there.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's him.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then three.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then these guys will go one, two, three, four, five, six, there.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I can do ten guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's that first guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then this guy goes here.
[SPEAKER_00]: This guy goes here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Here.
[SPEAKER_00]: So.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then... Red?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, red.
[SPEAKER_00]: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not him, though.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know what he's doing, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
[SPEAKER_04]: The Marines basically move forward and take defensive positions.
[SPEAKER_04]: The crossbow guys can fire.
[SPEAKER_04]: Where do you want them to fire?
[SPEAKER_04]: Tower.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fire at the tower!
[SPEAKER_04]: Actually, eight crossbow guys firing up the tower.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll the attacks.
[SPEAKER_00]: Six.
[SPEAKER_04]: There are six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Dice.
[SPEAKER_04]: So a 20.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that's a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then a 12 plus 4 is a 16.
[SPEAKER_04]: That is a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that's two hits, and one's a crit.
[SPEAKER_04]: So keep that crit different.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then you have six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now four more guys, so roll those four dice.
[SPEAKER_03]: Was there eight?
[SPEAKER_03]: Because we peeled off the crossbows.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, that's true.
[SPEAKER_03]: Only two.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm sorry, you're going to have to roll all of them again.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, not all of them.
[SPEAKER_04]: One's a crit, one's a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: A 12 and a 20.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then just two dice.
[SPEAKER_03]: Just two dice.
[SPEAKER_03]: So two hits and a crit.
[SPEAKER_04]: So roll the crit and it's going to be on the first row guys or do you want to do the guys at the top of the tower?
[SPEAKER_04]: First row guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so the damage for the marines is one die ten plus two.
[SPEAKER_04]: So do the crit first which is two die ten plus two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Black's first, sorry.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that's seven plus two points of damage is nine, and roll a die ten to see how that goes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Actually, don't roll that yet, so that's one's nine, and then roll damage for the other two.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, okay, one and one's the other one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: One is five, and the other one's ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: So nine, five, and ten, and roll a die ten to see who it goes to.
[SPEAKER_04]: We'll do this.
[SPEAKER_04]: So the first one goes to the ninth guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll those two.
[SPEAKER_00]: One and two.
[SPEAKER_00]: So this guy gets hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy gets hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: And one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine.
[SPEAKER_04]: That guy gets hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that guy takes the first nine points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: That guy takes the five points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then nine takes ten points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, and now...
[SPEAKER_04]: Who else is seven?
[SPEAKER_04]: Uh, nobody else is seven?
[SPEAKER_04]: Fives.
[SPEAKER_04]: What's your dex charity?
[SPEAKER_02]: My dex is 15.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's your dex charity?
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, dex is 15.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, well, you guys get to decide who wants to go first.
[SPEAKER_01]: Go ahead and go.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: I feel Aristotle bash me and tell him to fall off the ground.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're gonna run after him?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'm gonna run after him.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to attack or just keep running?
[SPEAKER_02]: Would bardic inspiration be an attack or a bonus?
[SPEAKER_04]: It would be an action.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Actually, that's a good question.
[SPEAKER_04]: It might be a bum section.
[SPEAKER_04]: Which would be nice.
[SPEAKER_04]: Because you could dodge if you wanted to.
[SPEAKER_04]: With your action.
[SPEAKER_04]: Dodge, duck, dive, and dodge.
[SPEAKER_04]: And dodge, and dodge.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can use a bonus action to do it, and then you can also dodge if you want to use your bonus action.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, well I'm going to use a bonus action of bardic inspiration on, say, Merrick.
[SPEAKER_04]: Alright, so give him a six-sided die.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can use that six-sided die for any roll that's an attack, a saving throw, or a proficiency use for the next 10 minutes.
[SPEAKER_04]: And believe me, that's like 60 rounds.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, in-game, not just by your watch.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can you only use it once for a roll?
[SPEAKER_04]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_04]: You can only use that one six-sided die, but you have four of those.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you have to declare it before or after?
[SPEAKER_04]: He declares it after he makes the roll.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, nice.
[SPEAKER_04]: And he can decide to use it.
[SPEAKER_02]: What did he do?
[SPEAKER_02]: Did he sing a song to me?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: He sang a little song.
[SPEAKER_02]: I pulled my five and I was all laughing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Got to feel so inspired right now.
[SPEAKER_04]: And he's like, fuck yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: Pantera.
[SPEAKER_04]: He says your name.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then that was my... And you want to dodge?
[SPEAKER_04]: I want to dodge.
[SPEAKER_04]: Which means that attacks on you will be at disadvantage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sweet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so then it's me?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So then we got one, two, three, four, five, six would be my normal.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then one, two, three, four, five, six would be if I sprinted, is that correct?
[SPEAKER_01]: If you dashed.
[SPEAKER_01]: If I dashed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll use my...
[SPEAKER_01]: I will use my...
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll go...
[SPEAKER_01]: If I go to here, I still have the opportunity to dodge, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, you have an action.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will go from there to here, and I will use mine as an opportunity to dodge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to say anything?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to say
[SPEAKER_01]: Take the tower.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's take the tower.
[SPEAKER_01]: And archers, concentrate on the guys at the stairs.
[SPEAKER_01]: How do I say that better?
[SPEAKER_01]: Concentrate on the entry.
[SPEAKER_01]: Archers, concentrate on the entry.
[SPEAKER_01]: Take the tower.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I'm going to say.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: So Tyrus begins a charge.
[SPEAKER_04]: Anish for the next round.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here's what the enemy have.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nine, ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fuckers.
[SPEAKER_02]: We can beat that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fourteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fourteen plus two is sixteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sixteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: For that or the Marines.
[SPEAKER_01]: That was for me.
[SPEAKER_01]: That was for him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now roll for the Marines.
[SPEAKER_01]: I forgot about the Marines.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eighteen, nineteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're always ahead of me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_03]: Five.
[SPEAKER_03]: Gouge gets an air stole, gets a five.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's on last.
[SPEAKER_03]: Four.
[SPEAKER_02]: Four plus your... No, it was two plus two.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Minus.
[SPEAKER_03]: Four.
[SPEAKER_03]: Four plus?
[SPEAKER_03]: Three.
[SPEAKER_03]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I had a 20 and then I had one.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so the Marines go first.
[SPEAKER_04]: Tyrus yells charge, and the Marines rush forward.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three, four, five, six, and I assume what you want is for them to keep dodging, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: That is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
[SPEAKER_00]: So these are wide enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: We can go up in groups of two if the stairs basically.
[SPEAKER_00]: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
[SPEAKER_00]: Looks like it.
[SPEAKER_00]: And 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
[SPEAKER_00]: There.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have a bag of holding there.
[SPEAKER_00]: 1, 2, 3,
[SPEAKER_00]: 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, crossbow men firing at the lower ranks.
[SPEAKER_04]: Two groups of two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two groups of four.
[SPEAKER_01]: And these are the crossbow firing at the door?
[SPEAKER_04]: At the door of the men on the top of the rank, okay?
[SPEAKER_04]: So, all misses.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll four more.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nineteen, seventeen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Possible hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Those are two hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: One to tens.
[SPEAKER_04]: One died tens each.
[SPEAKER_03]: Then you'll roll to see where they hit.
[SPEAKER_03]: Who they hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: One hits the ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: The other one hits the two.
[SPEAKER_04]: The two has been hit before.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll to see the damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: One died ten plus two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then the other one.
[SPEAKER_01]: He falls off of...
[SPEAKER_00]: The other guy is...
[SPEAKER_04]: The other guy is... One.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's been hit before two.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll the damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, that was his damage, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: One plus two is three.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, and roll his healer effects.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's been hit before.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, he has been hit before.
[SPEAKER_04]: He goes down as well.
[SPEAKER_04]: The Marines have gone.
[SPEAKER_04]: Tyrus, your turn.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I have one, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seven, eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can't move into there.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a door that's holding.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a door that's there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: That steps up to a door.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm up to the door.
[SPEAKER_04]: You want to dash up to that?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: That means you will not get disadvantaged after a certain guy shooting at you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_01]: I got lost.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can't quite make it to the door.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's an X.
[SPEAKER_01]: There we go.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'll save my dodge.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Their turn.
[SPEAKER_04]: They fire.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're dodging.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're not dodging.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, from last round?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're not dodging.
[SPEAKER_03]: I ran and fired.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gouge, one attack on you.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eleven guys, I'll do them in groups of six and one of five.
[SPEAKER_04]: Firing down on your units, this is at disadvantage.
[SPEAKER_04]: So we'll see if any hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: None of those could possibly hit, so I'll roll five.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh wait, that was five.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll roll five more and then one at the last.
[SPEAKER_04]: Five more and one at the last.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, I can't do six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, now we're using that dice.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is the one I use to get people.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's got the nasty 20 right there.
[SPEAKER_04]: 19, that could possibly be a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: 20, it hits with a 19.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's not critical.
[SPEAKER_03]: Crits are only natural 20s?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: 1, 2, 3, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: Crits are only natural 20s.
[SPEAKER_00]: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
[SPEAKER_04]: That guy, and it does six, seven points of damage to him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_04]: He takes 14, and he falls.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's already been hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: He was already hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, shit.
[SPEAKER_04]: That was no thumb.
[SPEAKER_01]: That was no thumb?
[SPEAKER_04]: Fuck.
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_04]: He may not be dead.
[SPEAKER_04]: But he goes down.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And he will have to go through a life-death crit situation.
[SPEAKER_03]: You need to put him out of his misery.
[SPEAKER_03]: Everybody else does.
[SPEAKER_03]: Steps on the neck and keep looking.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah, shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: These nine, fire on your troops.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, I missed somebody here.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm sorry, I must have somehow... We had one, two, three...
[SPEAKER_01]: There was ten here, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four there, and then five on the other wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here they come.
[SPEAKER_03]: Here are six of them.
[SPEAKER_03]: There they come.
[SPEAKER_03]: Get rid of that die.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fifteen, sixteen, and nineteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: These are all possible hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here are the rolls.
[SPEAKER_03]: There we go, that's what I want to see.
[SPEAKER_04]: 14, which is 15, 16, 17, so one guy will get hit, and it will be a 1-10 plus 10.
[SPEAKER_04]: 5, 15, 10, 15.
[SPEAKER_04]: What are they shooting?
[SPEAKER_04]: Crossbows.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And here's the damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: 5, 6 points on that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm like, 15 points of damage?
[SPEAKER_04]: What the fuck?
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, fine.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, they've gone.
[SPEAKER_04]: Also,
[SPEAKER_04]: You see a cadre of men march out from behind here.
[SPEAKER_04]: I wouldn't say they're men.
[SPEAKER_04]: March to there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Basically, they're coming in to wipe their unit up.
[SPEAKER_04]: Humanoids.
[SPEAKER_04]: They're humanoids, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ten has gone.
[SPEAKER_04]: The next person in line is Merrick at seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to move?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, he's right there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, he's the black one.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll move this way.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six to there?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, that works.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you want to fire at who?
[SPEAKER_04]: You get to pick exactly who you want to shoot at.
[SPEAKER_04]: Vote for this guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, that guy has not been damaged.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Roll.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gouge, take that one.
[SPEAKER_04]: AC of 16, so you need an 11 to hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, plus five is twelve, so that's, you need four more to hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to use your bardic inspiration?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: You sure?
[SPEAKER_04]: It's only one die six, so that's only a fifty percent chance of hitting.
[SPEAKER_02]: How long do I have it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like six rounds you said?
[SPEAKER_04]: You have it for all this combat.
[SPEAKER_04]: You don't have to worry about it.
[SPEAKER_04]: For like ten minutes.
[SPEAKER_04]: But you only get to use it once.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: What I'm saying is the odds are 50-50.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I'm not going to worry about it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you're not going to use it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_04]: What?
[SPEAKER_01]: In that case, if he rolled, the next thing he re-rolled that, would that go to a natural 20 at that point?
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: It has to be a natural 20 to be a crit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just curious.
[SPEAKER_04]: The next person is aerosol at five.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you're dodging.
[SPEAKER_03]: If they're shooting at you?
[SPEAKER_03]: That was your... No, he fired.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, you're fired.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's right, yep.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, it's me at five?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: What the fuck am I thinking this whole time on...
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to take a shot at that guy, and this is me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or this is me.
[SPEAKER_03]: You are on the outside.
[SPEAKER_03]: This one?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Take a shot.
[SPEAKER_00]: Four.
[SPEAKER_00]: Five.
[SPEAKER_03]: Six.
[SPEAKER_03]: I can get on the wall right here.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can get right up against the wall and he won't be able to hit you.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you want to shoot as you move.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you fire at him and then you move up against the wall.
[SPEAKER_04]: What's your plus for a shot?
[SPEAKER_03]: Plus seven?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, the crossbow.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you need a nine.
[SPEAKER_03]: What a motherfucker.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know who that is.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thirteen.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thirteen, hit.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, one die ten plus four.
[SPEAKER_03]: And you know what guy that is.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's been wounded.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four, eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: You hit him in the chest and he goes down.
[SPEAKER_01]: That one, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: Next, Folsum at four.
[SPEAKER_02]: So do any of these guys, can I see them?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you can see all those guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's within 60 feet?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_03]: It is within 60 feet.
[SPEAKER_03]: 10, 15, 20, 25, 30, 35, 40.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So what I'm gonna do is that I'm going to...
[SPEAKER_02]: Can I make my action then move?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can do whatever you want.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to use Vicious Mockery at this guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So what do you want to call him?
[SPEAKER_02]: Or call him a...
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm looking at him and playing my fief.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm like, hey, you coward!
[SPEAKER_02]: You need a shot, why don't you?
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Vicious Mockery.
[SPEAKER_04]: So this is what that does.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your mother was a hamster and your father smelled of elderberries.
[SPEAKER_02]: So what is your saving throw DC?
[SPEAKER_02]: My saving throw DC.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where would that be?
[SPEAKER_02]: That would be under your spells.
[SPEAKER_02]: Under my spells.
[SPEAKER_02]: It says DC at the top.
[SPEAKER_04]: DC at the top would be 14.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's got to make a saving throw a 14 or better.
[SPEAKER_04]: And, unfortunately, his wisdom gives him no bonus to that.
[SPEAKER_04]: So he has to roll a 14 or better.
[SPEAKER_04]: 12.
[SPEAKER_04]: He does not make it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Which means that you do one die four of psychic damage to him.
[SPEAKER_04]: One.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's like, huh?
[SPEAKER_04]: And he has got disadvantage on the next attack roll he makes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so that is one point of damage, and that was like, who was this?
[SPEAKER_04]: This was that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: So number three, one point of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: He starts crying.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, that had to be a four.
[SPEAKER_04]: You have to do four damage.
[SPEAKER_03]: Psychic damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's just like, why am I here?
[SPEAKER_02]: And then I'm going to move with Gouge.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ursul, one, two, three, four, five, six to there.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then I'm also going, may I Bardic inspiration him as well?
[SPEAKER_02]: You can bonus action Bardic inspire him.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'd like to inspire you.
[SPEAKER_02]: See what I did to that guy?
[SPEAKER_03]: You're looking good.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Looks a little confused, alright.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's probably like...
[SPEAKER_03]: Good job, man.
[SPEAKER_03]: Try to do it again.
[SPEAKER_03]: Alright, wild sounds.
[SPEAKER_01]: So now there's a door here then.
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't realize there was a door there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the X I drew.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I just said it was like an entryway or something like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's an actual door there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you're fucking strong.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we're gone for everybody, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: All of those guys are gone.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're doing initiative again.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is for me, then?
[SPEAKER_01]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Four.
[SPEAKER_01]: And this is for the Marines?
[SPEAKER_04]: Sixteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eighteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: The Marines.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're glad about that.
[SPEAKER_04]: I know.
[SPEAKER_03]: They're good guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: Bardically inspired.
[SPEAKER_04]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Seven plus two.
[SPEAKER_04]: Five plus two, seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, you're doing the math for me.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_00]: So this is seven, and that is twenty total?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eight plus three, eleven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here is what they get.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nine, ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: So all of you get to go first.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the twenty goes first.
[SPEAKER_04]: The twenty goes first.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nobody is in view because I'm at the wall.
[SPEAKER_03]: Correct.
[SPEAKER_03]: How high is this?
[SPEAKER_03]: You said thirty feet?
[SPEAKER_04]: Thirty feet to the first landing.
[SPEAKER_04]: Where they are.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: What's my move base with scalability, wall scalability?
[SPEAKER_04]: It's basically half the movement rate of you, so you'd be able to climb up 15 feet.
[SPEAKER_03]: Am I allowed to not use an action and sprint climb?
[SPEAKER_03]: Does that work or no?
[SPEAKER_04]: You can dash, which means you use your action to dash and you go up twice, and you go 30 feet.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm gonna try to dash up.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you use your bonus action to sling your crossbow over your back.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then start climbing up.
[SPEAKER_04]: The thing.
[SPEAKER_04]: Three climber.
[SPEAKER_04]: Watch my fucking back!
[SPEAKER_04]: So, you climb up the side.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll an athletics check.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is a pretty low DC.
[SPEAKER_04]: Athletics?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: So it's plus six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ninety-nine.
[SPEAKER_04]: You do make it.
[SPEAKER_04]: He climbs up... Not gracefully.
[SPEAKER_04]: Not gracefully.
[SPEAKER_04]: He climbs up thirty feet and gets up to the top of the landing.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now, do you want to come over right now?
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_03]: I want to be at the edge.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm still there, but I'm going to put my mark on the wall more or less now.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, that is Aristotle.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eighteen Moranes.
[SPEAKER_00]: This guy moves to here.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_04]: Two of your guys come up to here, and they are going to assist you in whatever you want to do with the door.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: The crossbow guys fill in.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that's one, two, one, two.
[SPEAKER_00]: And they are going to fire at the guys on the landing.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that's one, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
[SPEAKER_00]: This guy will come over.
[SPEAKER_00]: Seven, eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's give you a chance to roll.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's do four with you and four with you.
[SPEAKER_04]: So here's 220.
[SPEAKER_04]: You need two more to do the rolls.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, and these are to the two hits.
[SPEAKER_01]: You need 12 to hit with these guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, but these are for their hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is for their hitting.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're firing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Firing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, they're hitting.
[SPEAKER_04]: So one hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fourteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: You get one fourteen?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: One hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: So each of you get a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: One die ten.
[SPEAKER_01]: One.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, that's three points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Six, that is eight points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll to see who you hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: One die, do a one die twenty.
[SPEAKER_03]: Twelve.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twelve.
[SPEAKER_03]: Realize you're all well-trained by women.
[SPEAKER_03]: But tonight, the banner is a tavern.
[SPEAKER_03]: The seat can stay up in the bathroom.
[SPEAKER_03]: Roll to see who you hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll a 20.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ten, okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that was eight points of damage?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's what you guys do.
[SPEAKER_00]: And those are the Marines.
[SPEAKER_00]: The next person is... Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's got them.
[SPEAKER_03]: He'll mark them off as they're going down.
[SPEAKER_04]: He was up on the second floor.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, let's see.
[SPEAKER_04]: We have Tyrus at 11 and we have Merrick at 11.
[SPEAKER_04]: You have more dexterity, I think.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, go ahead.
[SPEAKER_02]: What are you going to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh yeah, I forgot.
[SPEAKER_02]: So am I right here?
[SPEAKER_02]: Is that me?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm going to move this way, kind of towards the door, 30 feet.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to go to there?
[SPEAKER_04]: Or do you want to be behind your archer guy, I mean your shield wall guys?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll just go right here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Behind the archers?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, and then I'll fire at him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Anyone specific?
[SPEAKER_04]: Go top deck.
[SPEAKER_04]: The guy that was just hit with the eight?
[SPEAKER_04]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nice shirt.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, 16, plus you get a plus five, you need to roll an 11 to hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: One.
[SPEAKER_04]: Uh-oh.
[SPEAKER_04]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: Man, you're having a hard time with it.
I know.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where's your turkey die?
[SPEAKER_03]: Fuckin' roll, you'd be rollin' your turkey die.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean... Well, don't, don't, don't roll.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hey, hey, hey.
[SPEAKER_03]: Only when you need it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Easy, easy, easy.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're burning the luck off.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so I'm gonna yell, we need to warn the ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have to get to the top to warn the ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I'm gonna yell as I go full force with everything I have into the door with these other two guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so this is how it's gonna work.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is a DC, you're trying to bust this door down.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is a wooden reinforced door.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is a DC 20 roll.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: The guys are helping you.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you get advantage with this, okay?
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: They're assisting you.
[SPEAKER_04]: It is a strength-based roll, so you get a plus three.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I'm 16 plus three.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you have to roll a 17 on two dice, one of the two dice, to be able to bust this door down.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's with the help?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's because of the reinforced door.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I keep erasing these guys accidentally.
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't worry about it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know, but I mean, I just do my own.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: Big whammies.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eighteen!
[SPEAKER_04]: You smash your shoulder into the side with your guys smashing into you and you hear the crack of the bar on the other side.
[SPEAKER_04]: Obviously it was wooden.
[SPEAKER_04]: Luckily it was wooden and not metal.
[SPEAKER_04]: And the door busts in.
[SPEAKER_04]: You look into the room.
[SPEAKER_04]: The bottom of the floor.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're going to have to draw this over here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's see about this.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven, twelve, thirteen.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you see me on the edge just hanging so nobody's shooting at me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hopefully this round.
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, it's not that big.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's the front of the building.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: The stone works pretty good.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's pretty even.
[SPEAKER_03]: True work, square work.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you bust into the first floor, and you see five of these creatures right there.
[SPEAKER_04]: One of them, the guy in the middle, that's the H, is wearing a breastplate.
[SPEAKER_04]: And as soon as you bust in the door, he's like, you know, basically challenges you to combat.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's see what else.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you broke in, that was your action.
[SPEAKER_04]: The enemy gets to act.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy moves forward to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's your AC?
[SPEAKER_01]: AC, 18, because I have my shield out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, he attacks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's see about this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Needs a three in order to hit me.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's a level 20 level.
[SPEAKER_04]: Miss, raise off your shield, attacks again, he gets two attacks.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sixteen, that is a hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thanks for that character.
[SPEAKER_04]: He does three, four, five points of damage to you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Apparently ain't got it.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy moves to here.
[SPEAKER_04]: He attacks you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_03]: You just let me know when I can yell.
[SPEAKER_03]: I know my turn's already over.
[SPEAKER_03]: So if it has to be until next turn, I just want to yell something.
[SPEAKER_03]: That will give your position away.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, because I'm already right there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eleven guys, fire down on your men.
[SPEAKER_04]: Thirteen could possibly be hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here's the roll again.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eighteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: So thirteen hits, and it's on three.
[SPEAKER_04]: He takes nine, ten, eleven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Another man falls.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, that was one tooth.
[SPEAKER_03]: One and it goes down, I'm getting pissed.
[SPEAKER_03]: We lost one thumb and one tooth.
[SPEAKER_03]: Five.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fifteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ooh, that's possibly three hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eighteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: And here are the rolls.
[SPEAKER_04]: One hit, and that is on...
[SPEAKER_04]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Stop it with the nines.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's going to hit Mr. Nine, and Mr. Nine takes six points of damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: So one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine.
[SPEAKER_00]: That guy's gone.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not gone.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's damaged.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's where he got hit though.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then number three is gone.
[SPEAKER_00]: That guy is gone.
[SPEAKER_00]: These guys fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thirteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Those are possible hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll again.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four more.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fifteen, seventeen, twenty, these are possible hits.
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_00]: These guys march to here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sorry about that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to move this down to here because I've got the map that I have to do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, I'm going to make this Marines.
[SPEAKER_00]: Marr.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, Anish.
[SPEAKER_04]: Wait.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, did you go?
[SPEAKER_04]: You didn't go.
[SPEAKER_02]: We had a shitty roll last round.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I forgot about it.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I am going to...
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to do what I can.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to rush out, because I can move 30 feet total in a round, correct?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I'm going to run out 15 feet.
[SPEAKER_02]: One, two, three.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can I see this guy again?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, I'm going to vicious mockerate him again.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, here's his saving throw.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_04]: He makes it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll a one die four.
[SPEAKER_04]: He takes half damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Two.
[SPEAKER_04]: Two, he takes one point of damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Again.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, he takes damage from him?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Psychological damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: And they, do you want to run back?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_02]: He just pops out.
[SPEAKER_02]: He missed me.
[SPEAKER_02]: That was great.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to do your Marines for your 18?
[SPEAKER_04]: 20.
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus something.
[SPEAKER_01]: 22.
[SPEAKER_01]: 15, 16, 17 for me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Shit.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to need it too.
[SPEAKER_03]: 21.
[SPEAKER_03]: 21 for Aristotle.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's a 9 total.
[SPEAKER_02]: 9 total.
[SPEAKER_04]: I got a 10 total.
[SPEAKER_04]: 10 total, Leo.
[SPEAKER_04]: 10?
[SPEAKER_04]: And they get a... total.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so the Marines go first.
[SPEAKER_01]: These are included in those.
[SPEAKER_01]: These guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Those guys are included.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the guys over here are also included.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here we can race this now.
[SPEAKER_01]: And your line was right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, the Marines first.
[SPEAKER_04]: Did you want to basically say charge?
[SPEAKER_03]: I think you're kind of in a doorway.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because you bastard got met with him.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you've got two marines behind you.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can have them move in and attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you want to yell at your man charge, you can do that as well.
[SPEAKER_04]: But these guys are kind of defending.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to yell to these guys for sure, attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm going to say
[SPEAKER_04]: So allies can move through you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So one guy can go here.
[SPEAKER_04]: The other guy can go here.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I'm going to say...
[SPEAKER_04]: So these are Marines, so we'll do that.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm going to... You want another color for them?
[SPEAKER_04]: Blue.
[SPEAKER_04]: We have blue.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll use blue.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, Marine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Water.
[SPEAKER_01]: See?
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm going to say... Marine.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they're going to attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy attacks that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll the attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm going to say take the keep so that hopefully maybe a couple of other guys will help us up into this, into here.
[SPEAKER_01]: So this is for these guys?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm rolling for these guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: 14, attack onto that, plus 4 is a 18.
[SPEAKER_04]: He hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: 1 die 8 in damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: 2 plus 2 is 4.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy attacks the main guy?
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Misses.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, that's those marines, these marines.
[SPEAKER_01]: You got archers.
[SPEAKER_01]: I got archers out here.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do I got?
[SPEAKER_01]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think I got enough dice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here's two sets of four.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so these are for the first four.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twenty is a hit, nineteen is a hit, and a fifteen is a hit, so let's do the damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: First off, do the twenty, which is two die ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eleven plus two is thirteen, and roll on who that is, a ten-sided die.
[SPEAKER_02]: Number one.
[SPEAKER_02]: One, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: The one that rubber's a needle in it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Folsom.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that guy dies.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll the next hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: One die ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: One die ten for that one.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four.
[SPEAKER_04]: Is going to be six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll to see who it hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_04]: And how much was the damage he got?
[SPEAKER_04]: Four?
[SPEAKER_04]: Four.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then last guy rolled the damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: One die ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: One.
[SPEAKER_04]: So three points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: And who's it on?
[SPEAKER_04]: Five.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: So then I need my next four.
[SPEAKER_04]: Your next four.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fourteen is a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nine to eleven, and then roll who it's on.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eleven to number nine again.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that guy goes down.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they're starting to drop.
[SPEAKER_01]: So those are my Marines.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty-one goes next.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can't tell you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Aristotle.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Socrates, Aristotle.
[SPEAKER_04]: So can I... You pull yourself over to the side.
[SPEAKER_04]: Pull myself over to the side.
[SPEAKER_04]: Which costs double movement, which is ten movement points instead of five movement points.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that's the here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so I am there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, how tall is this here?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's another 10 feet up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Another 10 feet to the very, to the lighthouse part.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And is it like open?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is there like a fire burning on up there?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's where you signal.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's where you would signal.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's no fire up there right now though.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so that's all my movement this round.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, that's just 10 feet of it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, 10 feet of it.
[SPEAKER_03]: And you have 30 feet of it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Motherfucker.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm gonna go straight into the guy that's looking at me crying.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's pretty much crying.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you move another five feet to there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I move all the way against this wall?
[SPEAKER_03]: To fight him?
[SPEAKER_03]: If you want to.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I'm just trying to kind of cape out of the archer's way if possible.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that's 20 feet of your movement at this point.
[SPEAKER_04]: You move out of the way of the archers and you bonus weapon, pull out your... Scimitar.
[SPEAKER_04]: Scimitar.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then attack.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: What's your plus bonus attack?
[SPEAKER_03]: Attack bonus with my Scimitar is plus nine.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Roll your attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twelve plus nine is twenty-one.
[SPEAKER_04]: That is a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: The damage is one die six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Plus six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Go up behind him and slash his throat from behind.
[SPEAKER_04]: He goes down.
[SPEAKER_04]: Still crying.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's your turn.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Me.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes, Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I am going to swing on this big bad mother trucker that's in front of me right here, and I have to hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: With your line sword you have a plus five.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: So plus five.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's it to hit?
[SPEAKER_01]: Where is it at?
[SPEAKER_01]: Here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Slash this out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, so just whatever I roll, I get plus five to that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's too easy.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm looking for Thacko here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah, Thacko.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so...
[SPEAKER_04]: Eight plus five is 13.
[SPEAKER_04]: It rings off his shield.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now, do you want to try and move at all?
[SPEAKER_04]: Like, if you move back, they'll get opportunity attacks, or you could just stay there and, like, keep doing combat.
[SPEAKER_01]: And... Can I...
[SPEAKER_01]: See, if I bolt past them... Oh, see, this is dumb.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you bolt past them, there'll be opportunity.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you have to push them out of the way.
[SPEAKER_04]: You've already done your attack action this turn.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, right.
[SPEAKER_01]: But just for argument's sake for later on, could I have tried to push past them?
[SPEAKER_01]: That would have been an attack, and then move?
[SPEAKER_01]: You could have pushed one, and if you'd hit the floor, you could have kept moving.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I would have rolled an attack, basically, for that push.
[SPEAKER_04]: For the push, for the shove.
[SPEAKER_04]: However, that other guy, as you move out of this area, he gets an opportunity to attack on you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Copy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, that's just a clarification from down the road.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'm just going to stay there and stay engaged.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy hit him, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, he missed.
[SPEAKER_01]: But he swung at him.
[SPEAKER_01]: He swung at him, but he missed.
[SPEAKER_04]: Alright, Merrick.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, I'm gonna... Back here.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm gonna... How far is that in?
[SPEAKER_00]: Twenty feet.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's like one, two, three, fifteen feet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Roughly.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, that's the doorway, huh?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, it's actually out here like this is really where it is.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah?
[SPEAKER_03]: Alright, I'm just trying to see where I am on this.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna fire on a guy in front of Aristotle's.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you see Aristotle coming up and you shoot at the next guy and range.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll a 20.
[SPEAKER_02]: Come on baby!
[SPEAKER_04]: 9 plus 5 is 13.
[SPEAKER_04]: So if you do your barding inspiration and you get to roll that 1 die 6, you only have a 16% chance of not being able to hit him with that.
[SPEAKER_02]: That hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: 1 die 8 in damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four plus three?
[SPEAKER_04]: It's three, wait for... Four, it's your longbow.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, yeah, plus three.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so seven points of damage to each one.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, do you want to move at all, or are you happy with where you are?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll show right there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: They go.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy attacks your marine.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sixteen hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: He does 1.8 of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_04]: He attacks again.
[SPEAKER_04]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that Marine gets five off him though.
[SPEAKER_03]: So we got a big guy up front swinging twice.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy attacks you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eighteen hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: Does seven, nine points of damage to you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, I'm at one.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I'm right there, I witness him just get fucking... You're not right there, you don't see what's happening.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're around the corner over here.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's above, I thought.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, he's down below, but I'm... Oh, you're below!
[SPEAKER_03]: He's above.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's below in the building.
[SPEAKER_03]: Inside the building.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, so these are guys that aren't up here.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're in the building below.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, now I get it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Now I get it.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm with ya.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm with ya.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then, finally, Folsum, what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_04]: What I'm gonna do...
[SPEAKER_02]: I am going to... Take...
[SPEAKER_02]: Go off this way.
[SPEAKER_02]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_02]: Still be hugging the wall.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then, is there any way I can see Tyrus in there?
[SPEAKER_02]: He's in the doorway, you see him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, I'm gonna cast Healing Words on Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or healing word on Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you know what that is.
[SPEAKER_04]: A one die four plus your charisma bonus, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: I only get to use it once, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a spell slot.
[SPEAKER_04]: You have two spell slots.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right here?
[SPEAKER_03]: Those two spell slots?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_04]: First of all the spell slots, he's got two.
[SPEAKER_04]: So he's got to mark one of his spell slots off.
[SPEAKER_04]: So he's used one.
[SPEAKER_04]: Until he rests and can...
[SPEAKER_04]: When he takes a long rest, he gets one back.
[SPEAKER_02]: He gets them all back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, in that case, I will...
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know if you would have seen him.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, you're running that way, but I don't know if he's through the doorway, because you were, what?
[SPEAKER_03]: Back here.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's running the doorway.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can see his ass.
[SPEAKER_03]: You probably hear him screaming.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yo, that sucks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'll use the healing words on Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So mark off one spell slot.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is that a one?
[SPEAKER_04]: You roll the one.
[SPEAKER_04]: You gain five hit points back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Man, I could have been a lot better than a spell slot.
[SPEAKER_02]: Whoa!
[SPEAKER_02]: Healed my butthole!
[SPEAKER_02]: All right, and then bomb.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Marines, that's up to them, I guess, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, they get to go now.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, the Marines have already gone.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I say, we did those, so now it's all up to them.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_04]: God, each other.
[SPEAKER_04]: Shut them down, bro.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, wait a second.
[SPEAKER_04]: So we did those guys attacking?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, those guys attacked.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right, and we did the attack with these guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: Did I do these guys?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, I don't think they have shot.
[SPEAKER_03]: You only did these guys.
[SPEAKER_03]: You did not do any of the archers.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so I'm doing it a little bit out of order.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm sorry.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four attacks on the Marines.
[SPEAKER_04]: Three possible hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four more.
[SPEAKER_04]: One possible hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nine guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four more.
[SPEAKER_04]: Three possible guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: Two actually hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: The damage is going to be seven and four, and they are on thirteen and seventeen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Seven and four.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thirteen and seventeen.
[SPEAKER_00]: And seven and four.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, those guys.
[SPEAKER_03]: You got one more.
[SPEAKER_00]: One more.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fourteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Stop using that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fourteen, I'll roll again.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fourteen plus twelve, miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so they have gone.
[SPEAKER_04]: You got those guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: They moved.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: They're actually coming up to attack the Marines.
[SPEAKER_04]: Can I see if they're bows or swords?
[SPEAKER_04]: They have swords.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, they also have crossbows on them, but they're coming up to basically... Coming up with swords.
[SPEAKER_04]: These guys are pinning you down.
[SPEAKER_04]: These guys are going to come up and just mess up your shade wall.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's what their purpose is.
[SPEAKER_03]: So that was that round?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: New round.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: New and ish?
[SPEAKER_03]: New and ish.
[SPEAKER_03]: My Marines?
[SPEAKER_03]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, they're getting scared, pussies.
[SPEAKER_01]: Bubba G. And then I'll go ahead and do nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six, plus two.
[SPEAKER_04]: Six, two is eight.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_03]: Five.
[SPEAKER_02]: Five total?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four total.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here are the other guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: They get a nine, ten.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
One, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_03]: Didn't I win it?
[SPEAKER_04]: You didn't win it.
[SPEAKER_04]: What do you mean, win it?
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, you did win it.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's fine.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm not fucking with them.
[SPEAKER_04]: You do go first.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm just going to start fucking trying to clear house.
[SPEAKER_03]: Step to here and attack.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, that guy knows I'm there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: So there's no... You're not stealthy.
[SPEAKER_03]: You haven't been trying to stealthy.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, not at all.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, so I'm going to step there.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you step there, and which one are you going to attack?
[SPEAKER_03]: I am going to actually go behind going for this guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to leave the guy that's bowing up there, so I'm going to try to get the guy behind him.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Cut.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, it's a two.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eleven?
[SPEAKER_03]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: What about my...
[SPEAKER_03]: Bonus action?
[SPEAKER_03]: Uh-huh.
[SPEAKER_03]: Bardic fucking... Do you want to use that?
[SPEAKER_04]: What are my odds with it?
[SPEAKER_04]: So he's got an AC of 14.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you roll a three, you hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you got a 66% chance.
[SPEAKER_03]: So three, four, five, or six I hit?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm gonna use it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, damn it!
[SPEAKER_03]: I can leave that down there.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hey, gotta gamble.
[SPEAKER_04]: Even with inspiration, he misses.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's an inspired miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, these guys move.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's their attacks, I guess, huh?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: First off, these nine guys, three possible hits, and two actually do hit, and they hit for 10, 11, and 6.
[SPEAKER_04]: The 10 is on, and this is a plus 10, the 10 is on 15, so...
[SPEAKER_00]: 11, 12, 13, 14, 15.
[SPEAKER_00]: Another guy dies.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's one.
[SPEAKER_03]: That was a brown finger.
[SPEAKER_04]: We didn't really mind that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: He fucking stuck.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then the other one was on 17, which has been hit, and the damage was what?
[SPEAKER_04]: 5, 6?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: So he's got 10 off him.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that was these four?
[SPEAKER_04]: Uh, yeah, that was four of those guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anybody five more?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: See, normally I would be- Eighteen.
[SPEAKER_03]: Possible hits.
[SPEAKER_03]: I can't say anything.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twenty, the eighteen hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: Um, and it hits, this is one die ten.
[SPEAKER_03]: I can't tell you to- It's eight.
[SPEAKER_03]: Realize this, or- You better- I can't do any of that, because I'm somewhere else.
[SPEAKER_03]: Four, five,
[SPEAKER_04]: That guy's gone.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's see about this.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then these guys, these two guys attack you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: What's your AC?
[SPEAKER_04]: 17?
[SPEAKER_04]: My AC's 17.
[SPEAKER_04]: First guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: 10 misses.
[SPEAKER_04]: Next guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: 3 miss.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so now I am in...
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm engaged with two.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're engaged with two.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three, four, five, six guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: Attack down on your guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll do four first.
[SPEAKER_04]: One possible hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: It does not hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Two more.
[SPEAKER_04]: Both misses.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, those crossbow guys all miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: All these guys miss?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So now we have, what do we have in here?
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five still in here?
[SPEAKER_01]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy moves to there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Attacks him.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, and I've been on this guy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sixteen.
[SPEAKER_03]: But he turned.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hits.
[SPEAKER_00]: Four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is on number one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Six on him.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then this guy attacks him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Three, miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy attacks him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ten, miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy moves to here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Attacks your buddy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Five.
[SPEAKER_04]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: Um, okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's see.
[SPEAKER_04]: So they've gone.
[SPEAKER_04]: Um, then it is the Marines that get to go.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Your sergeant yells to you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Pirates.
[SPEAKER_04]: Are we gonna be able to hold?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Everybody into the keep.
He's like,
[SPEAKER_01]: The only defensive place we have is to get in here, and then we can fight these guys off from there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Basically, your commander, the sergeant, says, Tyrus, you're wounded.
[SPEAKER_04]: Get out of the way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I hear that from being up above?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is he up somewhere in here?
[SPEAKER_04]: He's right in here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you want to try and push, or what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I erase him because he's underneath?
[SPEAKER_03]: He's over here now?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, you totally can.
[SPEAKER_03]: Does that confuse me at first?
[SPEAKER_03]: I thought I'd come up and help, but now I'm fucking soloing up there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Don't worry about it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's go, guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: So as an attack, you can do a push where you can push somebody backward or push them prone.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the problem that I have though is I've pushed this guy prone, he's going to have an attack on me, is that correct?
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Not unless you move out of the way.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you push him back, you can move forward five feet and still no opportunity to attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: Basically what you're doing is pushing into the building.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I can push back and then move up to here then, as far as I can go.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can push him back five and then take his place.
[SPEAKER_01]: I heard him yell that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Push to the inside.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I yell or know that my turn's over?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, you can yell.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can say anything you want as long as it's not like giving a speech or something like that.
[SPEAKER_04]: I just yell, keep firing!
[SPEAKER_03]: Keep firing, assholes.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have to take the keep, and I'm going to push on this guy and maneuver.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you shove that guy with your attack as your action.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's my action.
[SPEAKER_01]: So this is the deal.
[SPEAKER_01]: And just to make this clear, he would go to here and I would go to there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you would open up a space.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So let's do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's push him to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I don't know if that's going to happen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so what you have to do is you have to do an athletics check against his athletics.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, athletics is plus five.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you roll your dice.
[SPEAKER_04]: 16.
[SPEAKER_04]: He rolls the 17.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's got a plus one, 18.
[SPEAKER_04]: You got a plus five is 21.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you push him back.
[SPEAKER_04]: To there.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you take his place.
[SPEAKER_01]: And T goes to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Correct.
[SPEAKER_01]: And now I'm in between these two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Those three.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, now I'm really fucked.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, the Marines... No, my bonus actions are gone.
[SPEAKER_04]: You still have your bonus action.
[SPEAKER_01]: And is...
[SPEAKER_01]: Divine Sense literally is just detect evil, basically, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lay on Hands is an action.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, now for the Marines.
[SPEAKER_04]: Your sergeant runs up to there and attacks this guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: He gets two attacks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Good goodness.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then, what do we got?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you remember his weaponry?
Nope.
[SPEAKER_02]: You do.
[SPEAKER_03]: I love my voice.
[SPEAKER_00]: That guy moves to there.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can keep doing that yell all the time, as much as you want.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: That guy moves to there.
[SPEAKER_00]: So 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
[SPEAKER_00]: We've got eight of these guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: We've got three more of those guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Attack on the big hobgoblin, your sergeant.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll twice.
[SPEAKER_04]: First attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, first attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nineteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nineteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Good job.
[SPEAKER_04]: That is a hit, and it's actually a critical hit because your Marine Sergeant is a champion, which means he gets crits on a 19 and 20.
[SPEAKER_04]: So he rolls two die eight plus his strength bonus of plus two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eight and six.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that is 14 plus two is 16 points of damage he does to this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's his first attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, so he comes in and crushes his shoulder.
[SPEAKER_01]: And his second attack?
[SPEAKER_04]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: Crossbowls.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll do the first.
[SPEAKER_04]: They're gonna fire on these guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: First four?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, and they're at a disadvantage though.
[SPEAKER_04]: They are at a disadvantage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Because they're dodging.
[SPEAKER_04]: I gotcha, okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: That is three possible hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: No hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ten more.
[SPEAKER_04]: For the next four.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ten, ten, tens, three tens.
[SPEAKER_01]: All miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: All miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that is, well, this Marine gets to attack that guy, so roll that attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's see, this is, oops.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nineteen, that's a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: One die eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Seven, eight, nine on that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right, and then this guy gets to attack that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ten, miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right, so that was the Marines and T-Bone have both gone.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: Airstall is gone.
[SPEAKER_04]: Merrick.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh wait, Folsum first.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is there any way I can climb the wall?
[SPEAKER_02]: You could climb the wall.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're right here, though.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where did he go?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, he's right in the corner, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, I'm going to...
[SPEAKER_02]: Would climbing up the wall count as my movement, or can I move movement?
[SPEAKER_04]: You have to roll an athletics roll of a DC 5, and then you can move half your movement up the wall.
[SPEAKER_04]: And if you wanted to dash as your action, you could do that and move all the way up the wall.
[SPEAKER_03]: Up to the very top, like I did, to like right there.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I will...
[SPEAKER_02]: Move over here just so I'm like more out of the way.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to move over to the left about like 10 feet.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then I'm going to attempt to climb the wall.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you move over to here and then attempt to climb the wall.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do your athletics check.
[SPEAKER_04]: DC 5.
[SPEAKER_04]: DC 5?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, no, you're rolling a 20, which you need a 5 or higher.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you use half the movement you have left, which is 20 feet, to move up 10 feet up the wall.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you're 20 feet from the top.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to dash?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I'll dash.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, which makes you 25 feet up the wall at this point.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you're 5 feet from the top.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're clear out here, by the way.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to move in with your guys?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll move in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right here, in front of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're going to be fodder for these guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or these guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: And those guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can move past them, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that possible?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, you can move in between your friends.
[SPEAKER_04]: How many feet did I just move?
[SPEAKER_04]: 10?
[SPEAKER_04]: You moved like 10 feet, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: What are you trying to do on your action, though?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to attack with your bow or what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_04]: With my bow.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so Amy will tell you how close you can get.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to attack these guys or do you want to shoot into the melee?
[SPEAKER_02]: I want to support Aristotle.
[SPEAKER_04]: You want to attack those guys up there.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I'd say if you wanted to, you could probably go here.
[SPEAKER_04]: That guy will move forward one, and then you can shoot whoever you want.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll shoot the one right above Folsom, closest to Aristotle's.
[SPEAKER_02]: Die 20.
[SPEAKER_02]: Turkey time.
[SPEAKER_02]: 19.
[SPEAKER_02]: That is a hit.
[SPEAKER_02]: One die 8.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're liking the turkey.
[SPEAKER_02]: Liking the turkey.
[SPEAKER_02]: Three plus five.
[SPEAKER_04]: Three plus three.
[SPEAKER_04]: Because you hit with an 19, which is your plus five.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you really rolled a 24.
[SPEAKER_04]: You would have hit AC 24.
[SPEAKER_04]: The plus five is your attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: The damage is on the one die eight plus three.
[SPEAKER_04]: Six points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: He does.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is this one right here?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's attacking you and Merrick shoots him in the back.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is the way Gouge likes it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: If he sees me up there, I just give a... That's it.
[SPEAKER_01]: New one, huh?
[SPEAKER_01]: New one-ish.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, we'll go for the Marines again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seventeen, eighteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Man, those fuckers.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Stealing all of my good ones, too.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven, twelve, thirteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thirteen.
[SPEAKER_02]: Twelve total.
[SPEAKER_02]: Twelve.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fifteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here's their roll.
[SPEAKER_04]: One.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eleven, twelve.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so, Marines first.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do this combat first.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy attacks that guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so we're just doing one at a time here.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy is attacking him or him?
[SPEAKER_01]: He's attacking him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ten.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ten, miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, this one?
[SPEAKER_04]: This one attacks that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Actually, no, what happens is, yeah, that one attacks that guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, that one attacks that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: Your commander attacks him twice.
[SPEAKER_04]: First roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eleven plus... Let me look at this.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eleven plus four is a fifteen miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, second attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: Thirteen plus four is a seventeen miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: Whoa!
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy has really nice armor.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, yeah, I guess so.
[SPEAKER_04]: That guy attacks that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, we already did that one.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, we did that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so that's done.
[SPEAKER_03]: Those Marines are done.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Crossbows.
[SPEAKER_01]: Crossbows, there's eight of them, so we'll do four and four again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they're shooting here?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seventeen?
[SPEAKER_04]: Seventeen is a possible hit, fourteen is a possible hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll those again.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eighteen hits.
[SPEAKER_03]: One.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you rolled five.
[SPEAKER_04]: So one guy ten, plus two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you rolled five, so you only rolled three this time.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm sorry, that was one guy ten?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Two, three points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, and then roll three more.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's three of them.
[SPEAKER_04]: 14 is a possible hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll again.
[SPEAKER_04]: Two.
[SPEAKER_04]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: That was it.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the Marines.
[SPEAKER_02]: Your turn.
[SPEAKER_01]: My turn.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, I thought I got a 15.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, you do.
[SPEAKER_02]: You get to go.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna stay where I am.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I'm gonna go...
[SPEAKER_02]: Right by Aristotle's here.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you get the one I'm on or this one?
[SPEAKER_03]: Which one of those two?
[SPEAKER_03]: You want to shoot the guy in the back, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Is he in front of me?
[SPEAKER_03]: Is he going to block it or can I shoot him in the back?
[SPEAKER_03]: These guys are arrowing.
[SPEAKER_03]: This guy's engaged.
[SPEAKER_03]: Does he get an advantage with someone engaged with me?
[SPEAKER_03]: No.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: He does not.
[SPEAKER_04]: You would.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: But you're not.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's not a rogue.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And it's not an advantage when he gets his back.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean a sneak attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: If he wants to sneak attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, yeah, I mean, you could do either.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'd say that, um... Actually, you would get advantage on this die, because he cannot see you.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you roll 2 die 20.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's not facing you, so you can get advantage on it.
[SPEAKER_02]: 2 die 20?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you take the highest.
[SPEAKER_02]: Come on, turkey!
[SPEAKER_02]: 15.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fifteen, that's a hit?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, you didn't roll the turkey.
[SPEAKER_02]: 1 die 8?
[SPEAKER_04]: This would be a turkey.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four, seven points of damage on him.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's what I yell as I see an arrow stick in him as he's in front of me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thirteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Mine action.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you move there, you have to disengage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: But you can do that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Two, three.
[SPEAKER_04]: With your action.
[SPEAKER_01]: With my action.
[SPEAKER_01]: Get to the door or open the door.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is the door open or closed?
[SPEAKER_04]: You can open the door without any need.
[SPEAKER_04]: The door's closed.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And if you want to see what's in there, you can, but you might open the can of worms.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sometimes I'm just like...
[SPEAKER_01]: Understanding the whole action of the game.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I'm going to...
[SPEAKER_01]: He's engaged with him or him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which one is he?
[SPEAKER_01]: He's fighting the main hobgoblin.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, but the hobgoblin is... Fighting him, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, the sergeant.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so he's turned to him more.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to take on this one right here and...
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, I can use my lay on hands as an action and still hold a dodge ability, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Damn it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sorry, Aidy.
[SPEAKER_03]: All we've done is reintroduce the big guy.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, no.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to put a coin there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I put a coin for my action so if he kicks it I know he's buttoned?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just doing some of this so that I don't have to do this later on down the road just to understand.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just talking.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I know.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm the worst for that.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, laying hands is my only action.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's all I get to do and move.
[SPEAKER_04]: But if you move and you do not disengage with your action, they get opportunity attacks.
[SPEAKER_01]: But there really isn't much place I can move right here, right now, to tell you the truth.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't get a bonus for attacking somebody else.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's a round, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Unless there's a fighter thing where you do something like that?
[SPEAKER_04]: So there are some special abilities, like pack attack, where if you're next to an enemy, you get to do more damage or you get as damage on what you're doing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I was just curious.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just, like you say, I don't want to be the guy that holds everybody up.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll go ahead and just attack the guy in front of me.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right, so you attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: Six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Six plus five, eleven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna continue to climb up the wall.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you climb up the wall with ten movements and come to there and you find yourself looking at Gouge and a guy that just got stuck in the back with an arrow.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you want to pull your rapier?
[SPEAKER_03]: You're right here and then there's another guy that's facing that way right now because he was shooting with a bow.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, you pull yourself over.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pulling out my rapier count as my action.
[SPEAKER_02]: Bonus action, pull out your rapier.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, perfect.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll pull out my rapier and attack the guy gouges on.
[SPEAKER_02]: This guy?
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so what is your add for your rapier?
[SPEAKER_04]: Plus what?
[SPEAKER_02]: My rapier is plus four attack bonus.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, roll.
[SPEAKER_02]: 16 plus 4, 20.
[SPEAKER_04]: You pull out your rapier and stab it into his scale mail doing 1 die 8 plus 4 points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Plus 2.
[SPEAKER_04]: 10.
[SPEAKER_04]: The attack is about as true as you've seen.
[SPEAKER_04]: This young kid, the 5 player, sticks his rapier into the hobgoblin's kidney and he just falls right there.
[SPEAKER_03]: So that's what you can hear.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just, fuck yeah, kid!
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, I think I'm doing alright.
[SPEAKER_04]: So yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: And now, Gouge, I think it's your turn.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm gonna step-step to here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Onto that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: So do you want to go here, where you're on both?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Uh, yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Here, but I'm gonna attack that one.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you move forward with your... Scimitar.
[SPEAKER_04]: Scimitar and attack?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_02]: I gotta be running low on arrows at some point.
[SPEAKER_01]: You gonna keep a trap?
[SPEAKER_03]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_03]: Two.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_03]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I do a determination?
[SPEAKER_03]: My human determination?
[SPEAKER_03]: Or does that have to be before a roll?
[SPEAKER_04]: Before you roll.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Human determination, you use...
[SPEAKER_04]: I get an advantage.
[SPEAKER_04]: You get advantage with every attack you get.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: So this guy's here and you are here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then, did they go?
[SPEAKER_04]: They didn't go.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: We did go.
[SPEAKER_03]: They did go.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I was last.
[SPEAKER_03]: You were last.
[SPEAKER_03]: I was last.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, Anish.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, this is for my Marines.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven plus one, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep, that's twelve.
[SPEAKER_01]: For me... Twenty-four!
[SPEAKER_01]: I get a fifteen for me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fifteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hope you didn't waste that twenty on initiative.
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, thirteen total.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thirteen total?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, that's ones for the rest of the night.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thirteen, uh, seventeen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Seventeen?
[SPEAKER_04]: Here's what they get.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, sixteen.
[SPEAKER_02]: One.
[SPEAKER_02]: So they get two.
[SPEAKER_02]: It'd be 16 for Merrick's 16.
[SPEAKER_01]: By the way, I haven't pulled out a tinderbox and tried to light flaming arrows in the middle of the battle like this yet.
[SPEAKER_02]: You first.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm obviously seeing they're probably going to turn and engage, but they have bows.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Crossbows.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: These guys, however, cannot attack you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Because those guys are in their way.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: What are bonus attacks?
[SPEAKER_04]: If you pull out your dagger with your bonus action, next round you'll be able to use your bonus action to do another attack with your dagger.
[SPEAKER_04]: Slash with a scimitar, attack with your dagger.
[SPEAKER_04]: However, you don't get the plus four for your dexterity on that damage.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: But it's an extra attack.
[SPEAKER_03]: So bonus will be whipping out my dagger.
[SPEAKER_03]: I will take attack on him.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're going to use human determination?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I think so because I rolled a 20, so I'm a little worried that...
[SPEAKER_03]: I've got to pull out Wagner's sparkly for my double rolls.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I'm going to determination roll on this guy that I'm on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Good thing you did.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nine plus nine is eighteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: That is a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: One die is six plus six.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thanks, Steve.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll go black six plus six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ten points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's wounded but does not go down.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right, number sixteen?
[SPEAKER_04]: You.
[SPEAKER_04]: Good thing I used that.
[SPEAKER_02]: How close are they now?
[SPEAKER_00]: They are one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven, twelve, thirteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: They are sixty feet away.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can I shoot at them or am I at a disadvantage?
[SPEAKER_04]: You'd be at disadvantage because they're dodging as they move forward.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: So that's why they're not full sprinting, because they're fighting the arrows moving up.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, you would get an advantage on that guy, because he's facing Gouge right now.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just like that guy did.
[SPEAKER_04]: Two to the twenty.
[SPEAKER_04]: Who said Gouge?
[SPEAKER_04]: My name's Eric Scott.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Five.
[SPEAKER_04]: That would be a hit, but roll again, because you might get a twenty.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you hit him.
[SPEAKER_04]: One die eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: Five plus three is eight points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: And he goes down.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, he's gone.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so now you're here, I'm here with this guy, and the next guy is right here with a bow, facing that way so far, plus there's one more.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: About how many rounds have we gotten here?
[SPEAKER_04]: I would say you've gotten about eight rounds in here, so this has been about 40 seconds of combat.
[SPEAKER_01]: No way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're good, we're good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, 12 arrows left.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right, the next one is 13 Tyrus, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: And Folsum at the same time.
[SPEAKER_04]: So whoever wants to go first.
[SPEAKER_04]: I went first last time you go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, because you got seven decks.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to use this opportunity to attack that guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that's my best bet.
[SPEAKER_01]: See, I thought he was going to try to untie his boot.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I was thinking about maybe attacking this guy, okay, asshole?
[SPEAKER_01]: Five.
[SPEAKER_04]: Uh, Marines.
[SPEAKER_04]: Your wounds are slowing you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Your sergeant, twice on that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fifteen and a nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fifteen hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: That is a one-die eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Seven plus two is nine.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is that on the big guy?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
Derek!
[SPEAKER_03]: Don't fuck that armor up, it looks nice.
[SPEAKER_03]: This guy attacks him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, he didn't get two attacks.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy attacks that guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: So this guy attacks that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_04]: Two die eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: He gets 9, 10, 11.
[SPEAKER_04]: He kills that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Where'd he go, Fred?
[SPEAKER_02]: Are these guys, or are these the Spots?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, the Spots.
[SPEAKER_04]: Moves to here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_04]: A Marine moves back from there, past your dude to there, another one moves to there.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that guy attacks that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nineteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: One day eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four.
[SPEAKER_04]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_02]: Dude, the Marines are kicky ass like always.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oorah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Go Grandpa Pete.
[SPEAKER_03]: Go Cannoli.
[SPEAKER_03]: Go Brother Dub.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's do the Marines doing fire on these guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I need eight for these.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I got four here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, wait.
[SPEAKER_04]: 20, 18, and 12.
[SPEAKER_04]: Those are all possible hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: They all have to be rolled, though.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, they're all possible hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that's going to be the die for the 20.
[SPEAKER_04]: So if you roll 20 twice, it's a 20.
[SPEAKER_04]: Otherwise, no.
[SPEAKER_04]: 12 and 19 hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: So roll damage on those guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: Which is one die.
[SPEAKER_04]: One die 10.
[SPEAKER_04]: One die eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: Plus two.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I have two hits?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: One's a one, one's a five.
[SPEAKER_04]: So two and seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Two, seven, okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then roll four more.
[SPEAKER_00]: No hits.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, the first group did quite.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: That was those guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: These guys were like, I can't really see you over there!
[SPEAKER_01]: Your turn, Folsum.
[SPEAKER_01]: So then, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's up to you now.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, what I do is that I rush forward with my rapier to attack the guy that's in front of Aristotle.
[SPEAKER_02]: And before I do that, I kind of pat Aristotle on the back and go,
[SPEAKER_02]: Way to go, man.
[SPEAKER_02]: That was real nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to give him bardic inspiration.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Mel, your attack.
[SPEAKER_03]: Attack at the... Love it.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I'm just going, how the fuck is he playing that flute and swinging?
[SPEAKER_04]: It's impressive.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's playing with one.
[SPEAKER_04]: Uh, five plus four.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's one of those, like, harmonica stands, right, that you guys can play and do something else.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, they go.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy attacks the sergeant twice.
[SPEAKER_04]: First attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_03]: The first time I realized my sergeant died.
[SPEAKER_04]: He does three for five points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: So it's not that serious.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sorry if it's a glass candy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Boy, it's so serious.
[SPEAKER_03]: The sergeant sees it coming right down on his head and just goes, Take my ear!
[SPEAKER_04]: Next one.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_04]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy moves to here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Wait.
[SPEAKER_04]: Draws his sword and moves to here.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy... Oh wait, these guys are on the roof.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're doing all the hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, wait.
[SPEAKER_04]: These are his in here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: I can do this again.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy was here.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll do these first.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy attacks that guy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is there three left up here?
[SPEAKER_03]: Not this one.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four.
[SPEAKER_04]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy moves to here and attacks that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nineteen hits him for five, six, seven points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: That one's big.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy attacks that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gets a twenty.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: You wouldn't be a crossbowman.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's see about this.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now I'm going to do these guys up here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so these are these three right here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's engaged, he's right here.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy attacks you, Gouge.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so he's on me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, here's the attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: 16, 17, 18, 18, 20 hits you.
[SPEAKER_04]: That'll be a hit because I have a 17.
[SPEAKER_04]: And does five, six, seven points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, that's nice for somebody else to get.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four.
[SPEAKER_03]: Five, six, seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy moves to here and attacks you, Folsum.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gets a fifteen, sixteen, seventeen, eighteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Is that a hit?
[SPEAKER_02]: My armor class is thirteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Seven, eight, nine points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_03]: You better use that healing spell on the dam.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Then we got the little fuck there.
[SPEAKER_03]: He moves up to here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not feeling too good.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not feeling too good up here, guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nine of these guys fire.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll do six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Three possible hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_04]: The last three?
[SPEAKER_04]: And then three more.
[SPEAKER_04]: Two possible hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_03]: My EC is actually a little bit lower, but it hasn't affected anything as of yet because I don't have my leather.
[SPEAKER_02]: I could use when he was like, I need help.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, Anish.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ten for Marines.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_02]: Merrick needs some turkey bacon.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nineteen total.
[SPEAKER_02]: For Folsom.
[SPEAKER_02]: Folsom.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fourteen for Merrick.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fourteen for tires.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twenty-two for Gouge.
[SPEAKER_04]: What's yours?
[SPEAKER_00]: Fourteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: And here are theirs.
[SPEAKER_00]: One.
[SPEAKER_00]: Four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Aristotle.
[SPEAKER_03]: I got a dagger and a scimitar.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I am shifting this way to attack him that's on him.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't think you can.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right here?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, the other guy's in the way too much.
[SPEAKER_03]: This guy?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_03]: Then I'm gonna attack that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: You attack that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Scimitar first.
[SPEAKER_04]: Scimitar with the plus nine.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eleven is a miss.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then left-handed dagger, which is just flat attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: You get your plus four and sixteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_04]: That hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now you don't get your plus four for the dagger's bonus and damage because it's on your off hand.
[SPEAKER_03]: I get one die four plus the plus two from the dagger.
[SPEAKER_03]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And, if you want, because you're standing next to a guy that's standing next to Folsom, you can do Sneak Attack, which is three die six extra damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: You see what I'm saying?
[SPEAKER_04]: On?
[SPEAKER_04]: You can do one attack, which is a Sneak Attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Basically, you distracted him with your scimitar and stabbed him with your dagger.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you want to do a Sneak Attack, you're going to roll a die four and three die six for damage.
[SPEAKER_03]: On?
[SPEAKER_03]: The guy you attacked.
[SPEAKER_03]: That guy, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Even though I swung with the scimitar?
[SPEAKER_03]: So he wasn't expecting another attack?
[SPEAKER_03]: Is that what it was?
[SPEAKER_04]: So the thing is, the sneak attack you can only do once per round.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: But it can come from any attack.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right?
[SPEAKER_03]: If you can do it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: This guy is fucked up, though.
[SPEAKER_03]: That makes a lot more sense.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's already taken a couple arrows, but I need him to drop.
[SPEAKER_04]: And there's no downside for doing the sneak attack because it comes back every round.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: So this would be my damage?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: 11, 12, 13, 14.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so distract with the Cutlass and then just slash.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now if you want to, you can move up one more.
[SPEAKER_03]: Just move.
[SPEAKER_03]: To here?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I definitely want to move to there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Would really like, prefer to shove him off the edge, but we'll wait till next one.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, Airstall is gone.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nineteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Folsum.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yup.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, I'm gonna back up.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm gonna be disengaged.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, you can disengage, which is use your action to say I'm backing up and not getting hit, and then how far do you want to move back?
[SPEAKER_02]: Um...
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm jumping off the edge.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to disengage.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I see him backing up.
[SPEAKER_03]: Stick to the wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: Backing up to there.
[SPEAKER_01]: How many feet can you go back?
[SPEAKER_01]: He can move his entire movement if he wants to.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can go around the corner.
[SPEAKER_03]: Stick to the wall.
[SPEAKER_02]: Kind of go around the corner there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Great.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six if you want.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll go four.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, to there.
[SPEAKER_04]: You go wrong.
[SPEAKER_04]: My titty.
[SPEAKER_04]: Folsum's first day of combat.
[SPEAKER_04]: Kills a man, or a hobgoblin, and then gets viciously slashed.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's a little worse than words, isn't it?
[SPEAKER_04]: So, how many good points do you have left?
[SPEAKER_04]: One.
[SPEAKER_04]: Anything else you want to do?
[SPEAKER_04]: You have a bonus action.
[SPEAKER_04]: Can you heal wounds with bonus actions?
[SPEAKER_04]: There are some spells that you can cast with bonus action.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think that Healing Word is a bonus action.
[SPEAKER_02]: But that would take another one of my spell slots, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Correct.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you'd be alive.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm assuming Cure Wounds is an actual action.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's see what Cure Wounds is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where's the ship during all of this?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, we've only done about a minute.
[SPEAKER_01]: 50 seconds.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah, it's only been a minute of combat, so the ship isn't, that's why I answered it.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not very far.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's just sitting there like this.
[SPEAKER_04]: Cure Wounds is one action, and the other one was... And let's see what healing word is.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's one bonus action.
[SPEAKER_04]: Because that's actually pretty cool about healing where it is.
[SPEAKER_04]: In fact, you can heal yourself while attacking.
[SPEAKER_04]: Or disengaging.
[SPEAKER_04]: Or disengaging or whatever.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think I'm just going to end my turn there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, and then... Did you roll a 14?
[SPEAKER_01]: What was yours?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, it was 14.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, me and Merrick are tied again?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Go ahead.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, so I'm...
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm then going to... You can move to there and not be opportunity attack because you're still next to those two guys, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: But I would be behind him more or less.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, but it wouldn't be like advantage or anything like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: If I remember right, he attacked him and he attacked him last time.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, I'm going to attack him.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's probably got a lower AC and I need to get some hits on something here.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, I'm going to attack this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven?
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven plus five is a hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the long sword is one to eight plus three I've got.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six, seven, eight, nine?
[SPEAKER_04]: I think that guy's been damaged.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think he has been.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, that's the wrong thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: The phone goes down.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: He falls.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, do you want to move at all?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I want to move to here so that I'm clearly behind him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you swing around that guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it buddy?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, you can...
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, you're using your guy.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're on the real shit.
[SPEAKER_03]: Merrick.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Your turn.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm shooting.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not gonna move at all.
[SPEAKER_02]: Adam, the one closest.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is one of these engaged with...
[SPEAKER_03]: Both are.
[SPEAKER_03]: He just stabbed your guy and they're both right there with me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, I'm gonna go after this one.
[SPEAKER_03]: Which one?
[SPEAKER_03]: This one?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So one by twenty, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sixteen.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sixteen is a hit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nineteen.
[SPEAKER_02]: That is definitely a hit.
[SPEAKER_02]: One die eight.
[SPEAKER_02]: Give me that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where's my turkey?
[SPEAKER_02]: One plus three.
[SPEAKER_02]: Four.
[SPEAKER_02]: Four!
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you don't want to move.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, I'm chilling.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Marines.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sergeant moves to here.
[SPEAKER_04]: And attacks that guy twice.
[SPEAKER_01]: That big guy twice.
[SPEAKER_04]: The first one, 14.
[SPEAKER_04]: 14 plus 4 is an 18.
[SPEAKER_04]: That is a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: One die, eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: Six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Six plus two is eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: Holy crap, this is going to take a ton of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Second attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eleven?
[SPEAKER_04]: Eleven plus, that is a miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: This guy, this guy moves to, let's see, uh, one, two, three, three, one, two, three,
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy attacks that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy attacks that guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twelve.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: One die eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: That guy goes down.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_04]: That is one of your guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: No attacks there.
[SPEAKER_04]: This one on that one?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, do that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's a miss.
[SPEAKER_03]: These two?
[SPEAKER_03]: They already went?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, they haven't.
[SPEAKER_01]: These two get to attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, they just came in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so they're attacking the big guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, first one.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sixteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: One die eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh wait, no.
[SPEAKER_04]: He falls.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then the guy next to him... Gets his attack.
[SPEAKER_04]: ...sabs into him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's an advantage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Thirteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Thirteen, and then roll again.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twelve.
[SPEAKER_04]: He misses.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, he fell.
[SPEAKER_04]: I wasn't expecting him to fall like that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Then you're Bowman.
[SPEAKER_01]: Bowman, I get eight.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's down.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's out.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's not dead.
[SPEAKER_03]: No possible hits.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's different than this game.
[SPEAKER_03]: You have so many rounds before you die.
[SPEAKER_03]: No possible hits.
[SPEAKER_03]: You go to your negative hit points.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you can go to like negative eight.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is he like a potential character or something?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, because the rest just pawns.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because nobody's helping them, so nobody's getting bandaged or anything, so they're just dying off.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he's got more hit points, too, so he can survive longer.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gouge on you.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy attacks you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Five, miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eleven miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: These guys fire.
[SPEAKER_04]: Only these guys can fire.
[SPEAKER_04]: Only five of the... Only four of the five because these guys are behind.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, right.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: One plus two...
[SPEAKER_04]: Both 20s.
[SPEAKER_04]: A one and a 16.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sixteen hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that's two, three points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that is on...
[SPEAKER_04]: Nineteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Three points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anish.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, Marines?
[SPEAKER_01]: Nineteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Marines are kicking ass.
[SPEAKER_02]: They have a lot of morale.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Eighteen.
[SPEAKER_02]: You get eighteen?
[SPEAKER_01]: I get a nineteen.
[SPEAKER_02]: I got a six.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's six total.
[SPEAKER_04]: Six total.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so Marines go first.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is mine.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so what happens is...
[SPEAKER_04]: Wait, did they roll?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, let me roll, yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Five.
[SPEAKER_03]: Six.
[SPEAKER_03]: Plus they go.
[SPEAKER_03]: Six, don't they get a one?
[SPEAKER_04]: They get a plus one, yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Six.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that guy surrenders and this guard, Maureen, pins him up against the wall.
[SPEAKER_04]: And he starts fucking.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is not Prince John's dungeon.
[SPEAKER_03]: Flashbacks.
[SPEAKER_03]: Your asshole puckers as you have flashbacks.
[SPEAKER_04]: This guy opens the door to here and says clear.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then the men file in to where you're at.
[SPEAKER_04]: And Tyrus, do you want...
[SPEAKER_04]: Wait, these guys are... No, no, that's up above.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's on top.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, that's on top.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's below us.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's up here, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, I'm moving...
[SPEAKER_04]: So, one, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to move into that room?
[SPEAKER_04]: I want to... wait, is it my turn?
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, am I next?
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, no, you're not.
[SPEAKER_04]: The Marines start moving into that room.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to move into that room, but I want to use my action to heal myself.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I don't know where that comes in.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you can do that.
[SPEAKER_04]: So what happens is, basically, just as these guys start coming up to challenge the men right here,
[SPEAKER_04]: All of these guys file in through this door into this area and move into there.
[SPEAKER_04]: So they're basically getting inside the tower and everybody in the squad is going to be able to get into the tower as these guys stay where they are.
[SPEAKER_03]: I can't give strategy or anything because I have no idea what's going on.
[SPEAKER_03]: So this is below all of us.
[SPEAKER_03]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm above you guys.
[SPEAKER_03]: Me and the flute player.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, I'm...
[SPEAKER_03]: You're next.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Double attacking.
[SPEAKER_03]: I gotta clear these fuckers.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so you attack which one?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm gonna attack the one right here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: In front.
[SPEAKER_03]: Scimitar?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Four.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thirteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Thirteen's a miss.
[SPEAKER_04]: And dagger?
[SPEAKER_04]: 15 is plus 4 is a 19.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Plus 2.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, it's more than that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, the dagger is plus 2.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, your attack bonus is plus 9.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: With a dagger?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: So that is definitely a hit.
[SPEAKER_03]: I've got to wait for a new round before I can do the sneak.
[SPEAKER_04]: Uh, well, no.
[SPEAKER_04]: The problem is you have to have somebody that is your friend next to your enemy to do the snake attack.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, no problem.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I don't get strength bonus on this either.
[SPEAKER_03]: One die four.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Plus two, because of the dagger.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Six.
[SPEAKER_03]: Six points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maxi... Maxi Pad.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maxi Pad.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now it's Maxi Pad.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: He passed away.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did he?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, he was Jewish.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we got that on recording.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you're done.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll send you the transcripts.
[SPEAKER_04]: 14, your turn.
[SPEAKER_04]: What do you do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Mine.
[SPEAKER_01]: You want to funnel into the room as well and heal yourself?
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to go into the room, but I want to heal myself as my actions, but I want to funnel into that room.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lay on hands is five points, just straight five points.
[SPEAKER_01]: Five points up.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm at max.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm into the room.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is this a room?
[SPEAKER_01]: Stairs going up or something?
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, you go in there and you're in the room with like ten other Marines.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_04]: There's like a ladder that goes up to the next level.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then there are doors on the side where there are barracks and stuff.
[SPEAKER_04]: Actually, it opens up into rooms around where there are windows that allow people to look out and fire out if they want to.
[SPEAKER_04]: But you see nobody else on this level.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And what I'm going to say is I have how many Marines, the sergeant...
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight left.
[SPEAKER_04]: Is that right?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, you have more than that.
[SPEAKER_04]: The number of marines that are left are... You have archers in there, too, or crossbow backs.
[SPEAKER_04]: There are three marines that have fallen.
[SPEAKER_04]: None of the crossbow marines have fallen, so you have 27 men left, basically.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: I should defer to the sergeant, but... Well, the sergeant basically says, form a shield wall, and five guys make a shield wall, and then behind him are five archers.
[SPEAKER_04]: Behind them, and they're waiting there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Wait inside this room.
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_04]: Inside this area, the sergeant is here, and these guys are right there, and then back in that room, the rest of them in fire.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sergeant moves to here?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's get rid of all these.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then...
[SPEAKER_03]: Except for...
[SPEAKER_03]: Wait.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm here.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm in here.
[SPEAKER_03]: And hold on.
[SPEAKER_03]: And he...
[SPEAKER_03]: Wait, he is on this wall and he has fallen there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_03]: And he gave up.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then you're forming a wall and then there's archers which are red.
[SPEAKER_03]: One, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's like this.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can only hold... You gotta take each spot.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's like...
[SPEAKER_04]: One, two, three, four, five men, and then behind them are five archers.
[SPEAKER_03]: One, two, three, four.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then the rest of the men are back in that room.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sergeant is there.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're in there because you're wounded.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I'm in here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: But I'm good.
[SPEAKER_03]: And that guy's on there, and this guy's pinned here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: And...
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm gonna say...
[SPEAKER_01]: Make sure they're dead.
[SPEAKER_01]: The rest follow me.
[SPEAKER_01]: And just up the ladder I go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: What's your alignment?
[SPEAKER_03]: Can you make that command on the guy that's on the wall that gave up?
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm just throwing that out to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, the sergeant is here.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just yelling, make sure they're dead.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, for the sergeant.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's in there.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm in another room going up the ladder.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Men with me.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you get to the second floor.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: You, Merrick, are outside.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, fuck.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look at yourself, dude.
[SPEAKER_02]: I am going to... You can run into the room.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can you fire and run?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna fire on this dude, and then I want to try to...
[SPEAKER_02]: This one?
[SPEAKER_02]: Get up the building.
[SPEAKER_04]: You want to try and scale up the building?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: That makes you very vulnerable to these guys, though.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're right there, aren't they?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, that's... No.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's the... Maybe even some of them.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_03]: But yeah, it's a lot of arrows coming at you, but...
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, I'll fire and then I'll run into the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: Roll your attack.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where did it go?
[SPEAKER_02]: Five.
[SPEAKER_02]: Damn it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_02]: Shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you run behind these guys.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's T-Bone.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, that's T-Bone.
[SPEAKER_03]: Put him back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, Folsom.
[SPEAKER_02]: What I am going to do is I'm going to cast Cure Wounds on myself.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll a die eight plus four.
[SPEAKER_04]: I swear.
[SPEAKER_02]: Die eight plus four.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twelve.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twelve points of damage is healed.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh my god, oh my god.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, it's not that bad.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, I feel kind of good right now.
[SPEAKER_03]: So erase your damage.
[SPEAKER_03]: Now, do you want to move?
[SPEAKER_04]: I would like to...
[SPEAKER_02]: And he's just out in the open, not even in the door?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, he moved in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, he's gone.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, this is now.
[SPEAKER_03]: There's Tyrus and there's Merrick.
[SPEAKER_03]: But we don't know that.
[SPEAKER_03]: We don't know any of that.
[SPEAKER_03]: You don't know if he's in or out, honestly.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you can't really play off of that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think I am going to...
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just going to peek closer to the corner so I have a...
[SPEAKER_04]: I can kind of peek and see... You get to watch Gouge get picked apart by these hogalls?
[SPEAKER_04]: Or vice versa?
[SPEAKER_03]: So he's back here watching.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Watch and learn, kid!
[SPEAKER_04]: Is a new initiative?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, these guys get to move.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, none of them get to fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: These guys move in.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's see, one, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_00]: They come up to the door.
[SPEAKER_04]: And basically, the crossbowmen that have been holding their action fire on the front rank.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I'm gonna get you, yeah, go ahead and roll.
[SPEAKER_04]: Five shots on the front two guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sixteen, seventeen, nineteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that's three possible hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: Reroll those.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thirteen, fourteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Two hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll two die ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: That is 9 plus 5 is 13.
[SPEAKER_04]: One of the hobgoblins drops.
[SPEAKER_04]: Obviously the one in the front.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's not him.
[SPEAKER_04]: That one.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, initiative.
[SPEAKER_01]: Marines.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nineteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Initiative.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_01]: I should go first, then the Marines.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_02]: I got a fourteen.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fourteen.
[SPEAKER_02]: I got a five total.
[SPEAKER_04]: Five total.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here's what they get.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eighteen to nineteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, that's great.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they go at the same time as the Marines?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: So... Don't bag it when you go first.
[SPEAKER_04]: Here's the deal.
[SPEAKER_04]: On Gouge, I'm gonna attack on you first.
[SPEAKER_04]: First guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: 20.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fuck you.
[SPEAKER_04]: 10, 11, 12 points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Attack you with a sword.
[SPEAKER_04]: By the way, I won't use that die again.
[SPEAKER_04]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_04]: The rest of the night, please.
[SPEAKER_03]: Roll it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Roll that fucker.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll take it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Fucking roll that thing.
[SPEAKER_03]: 19.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I had what?
[SPEAKER_03]: 12 and 5?
[SPEAKER_03]: 17?
[SPEAKER_03]: 17 points off you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Here's how you do it, kid.
[SPEAKER_02]: No attacks?
[SPEAKER_02]: No attacks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Those two there.
[SPEAKER_04]: First off, what happens is the Marines in the back get to fire again with their crossbows.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so that's our next... Let's start that off.
[SPEAKER_04]: Five of them.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, these are the Marines.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sixteen, sixteen, eighteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Three possible hits.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nineteen, twenty.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, two hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: And one to ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: One d ten, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: First one is a one.
[SPEAKER_01]: And a nine.
[SPEAKER_04]: One and a nine.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that's three plus eleven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Another guy dies.
[SPEAKER_04]: There.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys are all a reading.
[SPEAKER_04]: These guys move back.
[SPEAKER_04]: Those guys move back.
[SPEAKER_04]: None of those guys are firing.
[SPEAKER_04]: None of those guys can fire.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can any of the other marines that are inside do anything?
[SPEAKER_01]: Merrick, you go.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Where am I?
[SPEAKER_04]: You're in there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Are there people coming in the door?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, they back up.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So if you want to go to the door, you can go to the door and fire a lot of them.
[SPEAKER_02]: Will they still be blocking or because they're leaving will they be at a disadvantage?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_04]: You could go to here, you could see them, and they're like around here, you could fire on them as they go.
[SPEAKER_04]: Poke your head out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'll go up to the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right outside, like, and fire on one of them.
[SPEAKER_02]: There are like eight of them right around here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll just take my shot at, like, one of them.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do it.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, thirteen plus five, eighteen.
[SPEAKER_02]: Eighteen, that's a hit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Johnny Redney.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Go ahead and use this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eight's not a guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: One day, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I don't have to.
[SPEAKER_04]: Come on, turkey.
[SPEAKER_04]: Five plus three is an eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: An eight?
[SPEAKER_04]: And do you want to fire on one that looks wounded?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: He goes down.
[SPEAKER_03]: One with an arrow in it already?
[SPEAKER_03]: You're bleeding.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've got ten arrows left, guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: You.
[SPEAKER_02]: Me?
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: Both these fuckers wounded, I think?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Scimitar on this guy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Which guy?
[SPEAKER_03]: Right here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: The one on the outside?
[SPEAKER_03]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fifteen, eight.
[SPEAKER_04]: Plus nine, twenty-four.
[SPEAKER_04]: One die six, plus six.
[SPEAKER_03]: Whoops.
[SPEAKER_03]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Seven points of damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let me see.
[SPEAKER_04]: Get back up here, kid.
[SPEAKER_04]: I need my back stab.
[SPEAKER_04]: He goes down.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I stab out at the other one.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: A little left-handed backhand at the throat.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nine, ten.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eight plus nine.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, that's right.
[SPEAKER_03]: Seventeen is a hit.
[SPEAKER_03]: Seventeen.
[SPEAKER_03]: One die four.
[SPEAKER_03]: That is a hit, huh?
[SPEAKER_03]: Because I thought I didn't get any bonuses offhand.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, on damage.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, on damage.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: So one die four plus two because of the...
[SPEAKER_03]: Three.
[SPEAKER_04]: Three points of damage, okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So he's just kind of wounded.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I can't use this for damage.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's only saving throws, attacks, and that's my bardic little...
[SPEAKER_03]: He's playing that little tool.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, Tyrus, you and your men take the second floor and clear it.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, now is this the second floor, or is this the top?
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, that's the very top, but that goes up and the trap door is shut.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: However, the second floor is this, and there are ways out onto it this side.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so which would be this level.
[SPEAKER_03]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to go, and I've got several men with me.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Men, check these doors.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know?
[SPEAKER_01]: And a couple of guys follow me up to the- Your sergeant's still alive?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, he's downstairs here.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you try to climb up to the trap door?
[SPEAKER_04]: I try to climb to the trap door.
[SPEAKER_04]: And check it.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's bolted.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's like, it's stuck.
[SPEAKER_02]: Forget it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I straight check to see if I can break it or is it not even possible?
[SPEAKER_01]: Just let you know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Whatever you're more comfortable with.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Boom.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hits it.
[SPEAKER_01]: No good.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's very solid.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So is that my action?
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I go out?
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I go?
[SPEAKER_04]: You could probably do that next turn, but your men are actually starting to go out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Starting to go out, filter out here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's see.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is there a... All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that's my action.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to stay at... No, I'm going to come down the ladder.
[SPEAKER_01]: Since I can't break it, I'm going to come down the ladder.
[SPEAKER_01]: And in case it opens, I don't want to have an arrow firing at me.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to have a shield upgrade.
[SPEAKER_01]: And...
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know what other actions I can do in this round.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I have anything in my Explorers bag that will help me out here?
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: Anyway, basically, Folsum, you're there and you see these soldiers coming out of the side doors.
[SPEAKER_04]: They're looking.
[SPEAKER_04]: One comes up and says,
[SPEAKER_04]: Folsum, are you okay?
[SPEAKER_04]: He sees blood on where your wound was.
[SPEAKER_04]: Are you okay, boy?
[SPEAKER_02]: Matter of fact, I'm actually pretty good.
[SPEAKER_04]: I can't believe it, but... Alright, good.
[SPEAKER_04]: Must be somebody else's blood.
[SPEAKER_04]: And he goes on.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gouge, you're standing there facing this guy, and you see other Marines start to turn around this corner.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_04]: You and him are pretty much the only guys, except for Merrick, who can be firing on the other hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_03]: Wait, what did you do?
[SPEAKER_02]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: So... 1, 2, 3, 4, 5... Do it!
[SPEAKER_02]: Do it!
[SPEAKER_02]: And there's one on me, or is that one?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_03]: These are our guys.
[SPEAKER_03]: Blue?
[SPEAKER_03]: Blue, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Blue.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, I have my rapier out.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna run up next to Aristotle and try to stab.
[SPEAKER_02]: This guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: That is a 14 plus four, so that's an 18.
[SPEAKER_02]: That hits.
[SPEAKER_02]: One die eight.
[SPEAKER_02]: Three plus two, five.
[SPEAKER_02]: Five.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: This hobgoblin, seeing Folsom come around the corner and the other guards around goes,
[SPEAKER_04]: And like, drops his weapon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I yelp down below that we need some archers up here?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I'm going to yelp to that so we can get some archers up on top here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Get some archers on top!
[SPEAKER_04]: So they start climbing up the top.
[SPEAKER_01]: Left over one.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't want to take these guys away, but...
[SPEAKER_04]: These guys are retreating.
[SPEAKER_04]: However, this is what I'm going to say the round is.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to let this hobgoblin live?
[SPEAKER_04]: Definitely not.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you just attack him.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do your attack.
[SPEAKER_03]: Six plus nine is fifteen.
[SPEAKER_03]: That is a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to backstab with your cutlass?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, on this round, if I can.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so that's going to be four die six plus your four, or six?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, six.
[SPEAKER_03]: So that would be ten, nineteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so this hobgoblin just basically says, and then Gouge just cuts his throat.
[SPEAKER_04]: And he looks at you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, I look at him?
[SPEAKER_04]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Grab him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fuck yeah, kid!
[SPEAKER_00]: Fuck yeah!
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're gonna get three shots on hobgoblins as they run during this period of time.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, let's take those three shots, because they're not firing back at you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Eighteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: One hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, roll damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, yep.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's an eight, correct?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: Seven plus three, ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to fire on the same guy?
[SPEAKER_04]: He doesn't go down, but you hit him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to fire on the same guy or somebody else?
[SPEAKER_04]: Someone else.
[SPEAKER_02]: Twelve plus five.
[SPEAKER_02]: Seventeen is a hit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Got another seven, so a ten.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then one less shot.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four myths.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, these guys retreat to here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Alright, I'm gonna say the combat is done.